bild hier an den rändern deswegen war es
brennt es an vielen stellen
bild
[Musik]
einen wunderschönen donnerstag aber ich
freue mich dass die filme nachts
eingeschaltet haben wir werden heute ein
abend nach einem sehr nach richtigen tag
wir werden versuchen alles für sie
einzuordnen von der lage in der ukraine
bis zum deutschen film day und der
impfpflicht wir haben viel vor meine
gäste heute abend sind cdu-politiker und
bundestagsabgeordneter christoph ploß
mit dem ich mich ja schon des öfteren
leidenschaftlich über die impfpflicht
gestritten habe ich bin sehr gespannt zu
erfahren aber immer noch für die
impfpflicht ist den mann neben ihm
werden sie kennen reißmüller er ist
einer der wenigen deutschen schauspieler
ist auch in hollywood geschafft haben
und eng mit den klitschko-brüdern
verbunden an meiner seite wie jeden
abend bild vielzahl macht er berichtet
heute abend wie auch den ganzen tag live
aus kiew auch mit von der partie
stammgast und kultur lässt hans ulrich
jörges lassen sie uns direkt in den
nachrichten tag starten der mit einem
man kann es nicht anders ausdrücken
unwürdigen schauspiel im deutschen
bundestag begann worüber sich besonders
mein kollege paul ronzheimer echauffiert
hat
ja liebe lena während hier heute die
luft sirenen geheult haben und ich
gleichzeitig den worten per video von
brasiliens geht dem ukrainischen
präsidenten gelauscht habe konnte ich es
kaum glauben was danach passierte die
bundestags-vizepräsidentin
göring-eckardt machte weiter nach seiner
rede nach den emotionalen worten nach
dem hilferuf an deutschland mit
geburtstagsglückwünsche das war die
direkte reaktion auf die rede des
ukrainischen präsidenten der deutschland
kritisiert hat der auf die fehler
hingewiesen hat und der um hilfe ja man
muss sagen gefleht hat ich kann nicht
verstehen dass eine bundestags-
vizepräsidentin so wenig
fingerspitzengefühl hat dass sie
tatsächlich mit geburtstags wünschen
weiter macht und ich kann auch nicht
verstehen wie olaf scholz der deutsche
bundeskanzler ist nicht geschafft hat
auf diese rede zu reagieren auch wenn es
nicht auf der so genannten tagesordnung
deutscher wird auch heute abend nicht
mehr also der tagesordnung stand das ist
danach anders weitergehen sollte hätte
olaf scholz reagieren müssen ich finde
katrin göring eckardt olaf scholz
annalena baerbock sie alle sollten sich
beim ukrainische präsidenten dafür
entschuldigen was das für eine
veranstaltung war der mann der hier um
sein leben kämpft bank der um das leben
so vieler menschen hier schon trauern
muss der sich zeit genommen hat vor dem
deutschen bundestag zu reden wurde dann
so schroff abgebürstet damit dass man
einfach weitergemacht hat mit der
tagesordnung mit geburtstags wünschen
und das hat mich heute wirklich massiv
geärgert
das war in der tat extrem peinlich ich
saß ja im parlament hat die rede vom
ukrainischen präsidenten gehört das war
eine sehr bewegende rede die wirklich
sehr viele von uns auch emotional
berührt hat und was danach ablief das
war wirklich peinlich und beschämt und
ich will mal hier auch ein bisschen aus
dem nähkästchen plaudern das kam ja
nicht überraschend dass die rede heute
stattfand und wie die tagesordnung
aussah sondern man hätte all das schon
wissen können was sie ja schon zweimal
sagen und sich darauf vorbereiten müssen
und man hätte danach eine aussprache zur
aktuellen situation in der ukraine im
deutschen bundestag durchführen müssen
es hätte eine erklärung vom
bundeskanzler olaf scholz geben müssen
danach eine debatte bei der sich alle
fraktionen beteiligen statt dessen gibt
es direkt danach geburtstagsglückwünsche
und man fährt in der tagesordnung fort
als ob nichts geschehen wäre ich kann
noch mal vielleicht ein bisschen
vertraulich hier sagen wir haben als cdu
in den tagen vorher explizit darauf
hingewiesen und gesagt liebe
ampelkoalition ihr müsst die
tagesordnung ändern wir können dann
nicht mit geburtstagsglückwünsche
weitermachen und mit einer ganz normalen
tagesordnung als ob nichts geschehen
wäre und dieser wunsch wurde leider
abgelehnt und das hat uns heute in der
ganzen welt blamiert was da
stattgefunden hat herr müller hat es uns
einmal zu ihnen geschadet hat es uns in
der ganzen welt blamiert oder blamieren
wir deutschen uns eh schon seit längerem
mit blick auf die ukraine
naja erstmal schön guten hand an alle
beteiligten erst los angeles
[Musik]
peinlichkeiten da waren die deutschen
noch nie drüber
kann man verlegen es ist glaube ich sagt
alles aus das hat paul ja vorhin jetzt
schon gerade gesagt
dafür haben ganz einfach die worte aber
da könnte ich jetzt mit einer großen
lettern anfang von der bundeswehr
angefangen bis hierhin sehe und habe
auch noch keinen gesehen der das gelbe
ich habe es leider in deutschland
vergessen dass das gerippe zeichen auch
mal getragen hat dass die zugehörigkeit
und in
zusammenhalt und dass man den soldaten
steht bei irgendeinem politiker gesehen
noch nie also
damals bei guttenberg als ich mit dem
mal irgendwo eine sendung war vielleicht
das war das letzte mal worauf ich aber
darauf hinweisen möchte ist heute ein
ganz spektakuläres
instagram video herausgekommen von
meinem freund gab schwarzenegger der
auch schon viele jahre mit vitali und
wladimir klitschko
befreundet ist also wir kennen uns alle
schon über 20 jahre ich habe mit beiden
auch einmal trainiert und wenn sie hier
in los angeles waren wir haben auch
teilweise
telefoniert wurde das ging jetzt geht es
im moment nicht nur 23 minuten also
andererseits werden sie geortet auf
jeden fall amt die beiden sicher in der
ganzen karriere immer für die an also
eingestellt oder hat
geholfen die im grunde hält verbrauchten
und
jetzt müssen wir sie halt unterstützen
und da gibt es viele möglichkeiten
tagtäglich es kommt an schon mal schickt
man hört man über die gleichen auch die
nachrichten die sind ja auch richtig
dass wir darüber reden das ist ganz toll
ich bedanke mich dafür dass man dass wir
immer sagen kann aber hier in amerika
oft verzweifeln wir schon zum größten
teil über unseren präsidenten beiden
hier wir haben die möglichkeiten
und alle sachen nach deutschland zu
schicken von alaska gouverneurin von
alaska hat gesagt ich kann die ganze
welt versorgen so viel öl habe ich der
präsident muss nur ja sagen das heißt
also wir würden aufhören und nicht jeden
tag eine milliarde dazu den putin
schicken um seinen bruder krieg diesen
brutalen unnötigen
schlimmen krieg zu beenden das ist ganz
ganz wichtig es ist ja so als wenn wir
benzin ins feuer gießen jedesmal und auf
anderen seite soll gelöscht werden also
wie gesagt da können wir danach spielt
das aber dass leute wenn ich das
ergänzen darf ich habe dass ich erwarte
gar keine entschuldigung gegenüber als
lenski oder keinen keinen kann keinen
selbstkritischen blick auf die welt ich
finde dass diese koalition sich vor uns
vor den deutschen entschuldigen muss das
war eine extrem würdelose geschichte und
mit dem geburtstag wünschen das geht ja
noch an aber
dann nachbesetzungen in einigen
stiftungen und gremien bekannt gegeben
unter anderem im stiftungsrat der
stiftung haus der kleinen forscher wenn
man diese rede von selensky gesehen hat
und dass danach kam dann war das
sozusagen auch die beschreibung des
hauses der kleinen der kleinen geister
in denen man da saß sei lenski hat mit
dem bild gearbeitet dass die deutschen
die mauer einreißen sollten die sie
trennt von der ukraine und von dem was
östlich von der ukraine ist und damit
dass in diesem bild ist er bestätigt
worden durch das was im bundestag
passiert ist weil man ich glaube dass
die deutsche politik immer noch nicht
begriffen hat dass die zeit von putin
vorbei ist dass man darüber reden muss
was man tut wenn putin weg ist wie man
der ukraine nach europa hilft wie man
europa neu ordnet die sitzen da fühlen
sich auf sicherem terrain glauben dass
die energieimporte öl und gas sind
gesichert wird uns nichts passieren der
winter wird nicht kalt und damit lassen
wir die sache mal laufen die deutschen
waren mit den beschlüssen zur aufrüstung
und zur waffenlieferung an die ukraine
aus ihrer sehr schlechten position raus
und jetzt sind sie wieder in einer sehr
schlechten drin für mich für mich als
deutscher teilnehmer der zeitgeschichte
ich finde es erbärmlich ich finde es
völlig unmöglich dass man auf eine
solche rede nicht sofort eine debatte
aufsetzt und über die situation in der
ukraine redet und wer die drei parteien
der ampel übersah lasst mich das noch
sagen paul die drei parteien der der
ampel haben eine ganz andere tradition
die spd ist die partei des friedens
nobelpreisträgers willy brandt die
grünen waren immer eine friedenspartei
die fdp war in der sozialliberalen
koalition auch eine friedenspartei dass
die das so an sich vorbeigleiten lassen
und sich durch die begründung ihrer
verweigerung der diskussion in eine
immer noch unmögliche situation hinein
reden und ihnen das gar nicht auffällt
das erlebt man wirklich selten sehr
selten pauli
was mich interessiert du hast hier
angesprochen das ist auch sozusagen für
die natürlich für die deutsche
bevölkerung einfach peinlich war was
dort passiert ist und das ist ja auch
das was natürlich wo uns oder oder euch
in dem moment am meisten beschäftigt nur
ich frage mich was er bloß gesagt hat
ist war ja vorher in der diskussion oli
keiner kennen den parlamentarischen
betrieb so gut wie du was glaubst du
denn warum das dann nicht verhindert
wurde lag es daran dass man nicht auf
die opposition eingehen wollte und sagen
wollte mensch okay da hat friedrich merz
einen punkt machen wir anders
woran liegt es dass ist es ja irgendwie
ja und ja also wir haben die debatte
auch bei drei tage lang ja ich glaube
durch koalition hatte angst davor was
sie lenski sagt das wussten sie ja nicht
also wenn selensky die deutsche position
zu sanktionen beispielsweise frontal
angegriffen hätte und forderungen
erhoben hätte hätte das natürlich in der
nachfolgenden diskussion eine rolle
gespielt also das wäre natürlich
aufgenommen worden von wem auch immer
und das wollten sie vermeiden deshalb
haben sie sich in diese völlig
unmögliche situation rein begeben und es
gab eine nach meiner sicht einmalige
situation weil der
oppositionsführer der cdu csu friedrich
merz unterstützt worden ist von einem
redner der linkspartei nämlich von jan
korte da kommt glaube ich dass hamburg
der hat ihm heftig zugestimmt also der
hat sozusagen von links auch noch die
koalition angegriffen weil er der
meinung war darüber muss man einfach
reden das war eine einem hat olaf scholz
ja immer gesagt wir für und bestellt
bekommt sie auch ja der inkom logan
genau mit dem slogan ist er bleiben dass
wir gar nicht reden sie haben einen sohn
im moment bekommt deutschland diese
führung nicht sondern deutschland ist
führungslos und olaf scholz hätte
natürlich heute antworten müssen vor
allem hat paul ronzheimer eben ja auch
ein paar fragen aufgeworfen die man im
deutschen bundestag hätte diskutieren
müssen wir müssen ja auch nach paar
wochen feststellen was ist gut gelaufen
was kann man vielleicht noch stärker
machen auch bei den sanktionen aber was
ist auch schief gelaufen und dass man
nur eine große debatte im deutschen
bundestag darüber hatte nämlich an dem
sonntag bei der sondersitzung das jetzt
ja auch schon eine gewisse zeit her das
ist wirklich beschämend und ich hoffe
dass wir schnell diese grundsatzdebatte
zur ukraine im deutschen bundestag
bekommt glaube paul dass diese koalition
ein schlechtes gewissen hat wegen ihrer
verspäteten reaktionen auf den krieg
wegen ihrer zu schwachen reaktionen
wegen ihrer verweigerung von energie
importen aus russland
es hat ja noch ein kleineres
sanktionspaket inzwischen gegeben wo
deutschland dafür gesorgt hat dass
sanktionen gegen investitionen in der
russischen energie würden die sensoren
sprechen ich gedacht jetzt muss ich nach
alten kameraden
hat es geht weiter mit christoph ploß
und den spritpreisen uns den renten
kommen mit hitze zu sagen paul tut mir
leid
die spritpreise in deutschland die sind
viel zu hoch und die politik die muss
jetzt reagieren die bürger müssen
entlastet werden die müssen an der
zapfsäule merken dass die spritkosten
wieder runter gehen die beste
möglichkeit um die spritkosten zu senken
während steuerentlastung die könnte man
schnell durchführen und man könnte sie
vor allem unbürokratisch durchführen
statt jetzt steuersenkungen vorzunehmen
verheddert sich die ampel koalition aber
im klein klein und die eine hand weiß
nicht was die andere hand will christian
lindner kommt mit bürokratischen
vorschlägen will eine zettelwirtschaft
an tankstellen etablieren am selben tag
widerspricht ihm aber robert habeck und
ich fordere deswegen die ampel koalition
auf hören sie auf mit politischen
klein-klein hören sie auf mit dem
parteipolitischen hickhack wir brauchen
jetzt steuersenkungen wir brauchen jetzt
die spritpreis bremse ja sehr wichtig
halte ich für eine forderung der mann
gar nicht widersprechen kann ich glaube
auch dass das kommen wird die frage ist
wie es kommen wird und wie kann man noch
sinnlose schleifen dreht bevor man sich
auf eine lösung verständigt hatte ich
stimme ihrer meinung über die gutscheine
völlig zu
es gibt ja diverse steuer ansätze bei
der mehrwertsteuer sagt lindner kann er
nicht weil europäisches recht dem
widerspricht könnte aber sein dass das
doch zugelassen wird von europäische
union spielt gar keine rolle es gibt
noch die mineralölsteuer man kann an
diversen punkten ansetzen um die steuer
senken und das muss schnellstens
passieren herr möller wenn sie uns hier
so reden hören über den spritpreis das
ist ein problem was uns hier in
deutschland sehr sehr stark beschäftigt
die steigenden preise gibt es denn auch
ein alltägliches problem ein
gravierendes problem was in amerika
stattfinden blick auf putin was die
amerikaner beschäftigt mit ihrer eigenen
wirtschaft
na ja sicher auch das ist klar ich meine
das wird hier sieht man auf fox cnn dass
man über alle sender informiert auch der
die reden von beiden
teilweise auch zum beispiel das fenster
lynskey der ja auch jetzt
ein tag zuvor bei uns gesprochen hat zum
us-kongress hat stehen der option
bekommen die amerikaner haben auch
danach diskutiert wie gesagt die haben
mich wie versucht wie ist jetzt ja heute
vernommen hatte ich habe es noch nicht
gesehen was da im deutschen bundestag
passiert ist gleich mit glückwünsche und
gleich das thema das erinnert mich was
uni vorstand sagte mann bilden immer
schnell so ein thema schnell loswerden
und dann wieder weiter gehen was wir
hier viel sehen ist ehemaliger bunten
der präsident trump kann man nur sagen
gott sei dank dass der im moment nicht
dabei ist weil der wirt der nato und
deutschland und der ukraine glaub ich
nicht allzu große hilfe leisten
wie ich schon hier die großen experten
sagten steht auch kurz davor dass er
wahrscheinlich damit muss man rechnen in
zwei drei jahren wieder zurück ist und
seine die er mehr ettmayer wundert's ist
eben halt china russland und nordkorea
war dort die diktatoren eben ganz
einfach diktatoren sind ohne
menschenrechte aber das ist auch
darauf weist das ist immer wieder was
wir hier auch erleben trump kommt rein
spricht man man sich natürlich bilder er
hat natürlich schon damals gesagt dass
die deutschen im budget vom militär
erhöhen sollen dass sie nicht von es
kommt nicht so abhängig von deutschland
machen von russland machen sollen punkte
öl und gas line und und und und das ist
eben halt trifft natürlich jetzt auch
genau auf den punkt das was er damals
gesagt hat das wird immer wieder auch
gesendet auch immer wieder gezeigt dass
die deutschen eben über viele viele
jahre
sehr eng verbunden waren und auch den
jetzigen putin eben halt auch immer
geschmeichelt haben und eben halt
sich sich das sind immer wieder bilder
die man eben halt das aufregend was half
vorne gesagt hat dass es nämlich das
angebot gab dass die deutschen
öleinfuhren aus russland komplett durch
einfuhren aus den usa ersetzt werden
können und wenn das so ist und
deutschland geht nicht darauf ein ich
gehe mal davon aus dass das im
wirtschaftsministerium geprüft worden
ist alle alternativen bezugsquellen dann
bestärkt mich das in meiner meinung dass
die deutsche politik erst dann für uns
für die deutsch amerikaner danny sachen
ist mir dass man momentan ziemlich
wurscht wir haben einen so hohen
steueranteil auf öl und gas transit ja
da sag ich ja wir haben einen so hohen
steueranteil dass man den entsprechend
reduzieren kann nein ich will ich will
tut mir leid das ist mir
der kampf gegen putin nicht solche
portemonnaie das ist mental kann ich
beurteilen dann muss man entsprechend
die mehrwertsteuer und die und die
mineralölsteuer senken jedenfalls wird
sich weiter von putin abhängig zu machen
bestärkt mich in meiner einschätzung
dass man in berlin immer noch daran
denkt dass putin auf die eine oder
andere weise überleben wird irgendeinen
kompromiss frieden mit der ukraine
eingehen wird ein bisschen beute macht
in bestimmten teilen der ukraine und man
dann weiter mit ihm politik machen muss
und das finde ich empörend weil mit
putin finde ich geht gar nichts mehr du
kennst ja meine meinung ich finde wir
müssen
es ist genau das
müller man hat aber auch gemerkt als ich
sie gerade auf die alltäglichen probleme
oder der wirtschaft angesprochen habe in
amerika kam auch gar nicht so
gravierende hervor wie ich ihnen jetzt
aus deutschland berichten könnte die
deutsche wirtschaft trifft es auch
leider noch signifikanter als die
amerikanische ich würde aber gerne an
die frage ein paar zimmer weiter geben
wie ist denn das wurde auch gerade
angesprochen die naivität der deutschen
zu erklären das hat herr müller gerade
auch angesprochen das ist ja schon lange
eigentlich klar war dass wir uns nicht
so abhängig machen sollten von putin wie
ist das zu erklären
na ja das sind glaube ich jetzt wieder
die fragen die in der vergangenheit sind
ja also was wurde seit 2004 10 falsch
gemacht kann ich viele dinge aufführen
die abhängigkeit von nord stream keine
wirklich scharfen sanktionen nach der
krim aktion genauso weitergehen dann in
der ost ukraine also putin hatte das
gefühl er kann machen und der westen
schaut zu macht ein bisschen was aber es
nicht so richtig ernst haben deswegen
hat ihn dass am ende mehr appetit
bereitet und hat dann dazu geführt dass
dieser große krieg entstanden ist und
ich stimme der uli umfänglich zu dass
die große gefahr besteht jetzt darin wir
haben über die verschiedenen pläne
friedenspläne gesprochen dass er wieder
einen trick anwendet und sagt ich will
ja verhandeln und dann nehme ich erst
mal diese gebiete und die ukraine wird
neutral und geht nicht in die nato und
dann kriegen wir das schon irgendwie hin
und der westen lässt sich einfangen
womöglich werden dann wieder einzelne
sanktionen sogar gelockert oder ein paar
monate später oder ein zwei jahre später
greift er wieder die ukraine komplett an
das ist ein szenario das wahrscheinlich
das wahrscheinlichste ist denn das hat
er bereits gezeigt unter anderem in
tschetschenien in den neunziger jahren
als man zunächst das land nicht erobern
konnte und es dann ein paar jahre später
wieder versucht hat und jetzt ziehen wir
auch wie er versucht syrische kämpfer zu
bekommen tschetschenische kämpfer zu
bekommen und sozusagen sein militär neu
aufzustellen und das ist das problem wie
geht man dann mit ihm um und das ist
eine große frage die nicht einfach zu
beantworten ist dann natürlich
sagen leute völlig zu recht ist muss
jetzt sofort frieden geben es dürfen
nicht mehr menschen sterben dem würde
ich sofort zustimmen die frage ist
dennoch gerade für die menschen hier zu
welchem preis die menschen sagen wir
wollen unser land verteidigen wir sind
bereit auch für unser land zu sterben
weil wir nicht wollen dass uns die
existenz abgesprochen wird und es ist
etwas existenzielles was hier passiert
von daher ist es nicht so leicht zu
beantworten
ich war einmal gekannt ruhig werden wir
noch mal einen eindruck machen zum thema
auch gas und öl weil das ist ja wirklich
das was putin treffen kann wir wissen
russlands haushalt der speist sich vor
allem aus öl der speist sich vor allem
aus gas der speist sich vor allem aus
dem verkauf von rohstoffen und solange
putin seine rohstoffe noch nach europa
und nach deutschland verkaufen kann und
perverser weise auch noch von diesem
krieg profitiert denn derzeit steigen ja
die öl und gaspreise massiv wird putin
weiter sein kriegs treiben fortführen
können und deswegen bin ich da völlig
bei herr jörges wir müssen den import
von öl wir müssen den import von gas aus
putin russland stoppen und gerade wenn
es alternativen gibt das was ich jetzt
von ralf müller gehört habe ist auch für
mich neu das müsste man in der tat dann
prüfen ist glaube ich auch ein wichtiger
als die kreise wissen genau will ich
natürlich hier prüfen aber wir machen
ist uns auch zu einfach wenn wir sagen
wir führen nur sanktionen durch die uns
überhaupt nicht treffen und die wir
selber gar nicht merken und das immer
noch zb nord stream 1 läuft und dass wir
zwar gesagt haben naja nord stream 2
geht nicht im betrieb aber nord stream 1
läuft weiter dass die bundesregierung da
nicht reagiert hat das finde ich ist ein
skandal und deswegen fordere ich auch
das nord stream 1 ebenso abgeschaltet
wird und dass man da wirklich die
gasröhre zu drehen wir dürfen nicht
vergessen dass die abhängigkeit von
russland früher ja genau umgekehrt
betrachtet worden ist da galt es als
besonders sicher dass wir so viel
energie aus russland gegen weil die
russen sind ein verlässlicher lieferant
die haben ja schon als sowjetunion in
der geschichte über den ganzen krieg
hinweg beim kalten krieg aber auch den
zweiten weltkrieg als er begann noch
geliefert
und insofern
galt das als ein privileg deutschlands
sein aber das ist sehr großen fehler der
große denker das haben wir das wiegt
dass viele gedacht haben das jetzige
russland ist eine kleine sowjetunion und
der unterschied ist die frühere
sowjetunion wollte den status quo
sichern das jetzige russland ist
nationalistisch und möchte sich gebiete
wieder ärger obernau wird zur
sowjetunion gehörte jetzt führer wenn er
durchgeknallt gewesen wäre wie putin
nicht auch so was gemacht hätte
irgendwann wissen wir nicht aber
natürlich hat die ukraine zur
sowjetunion gehört insofern gab es da
nichts zu erobern aber das ist auch der
grund dafür dass sie erwähnt habe man
hat das für besonders klug gehalten sich
von russland abhängig zu machen die
liefern sehr viel zu niedrigen preisen
nena ja liefern zu ganz günstigen
preisen deshalb hat ja auch rebellin
abreißen der itc
also was das angeht denke ich mal fast
die hälfte denke ich mal 40 prozent und
die das ist auch der grund warum angela
merkel an dem projekt festgehalten hat
auch die hielt es ja für ein ausweis
deutscher klugheit sich darauf
einzulassen und sie glaubte die kritik
aus dem ausland haben nur mit neid zu
tun die sind alle nur neidisch weil sie
diese bevorzugte belieferung nicht haben
und nun sehen wir was daraus geworden
ist und
ist von einem klumpenrisiko entstanden
ja also früher hatten wir kernkraft da
hatten wir dann auch kohle da haben wir
dann vielleicht die erneuerbaren und gas
und jetzt haben wir gesagt raus aus
kernkraft raus aus kohle und dafür
brauchen wir ganz viel russisches gas
und das ist ein klumpenrisiko das würde
kaum ein unternehmer in der freien
wirtschaft eingehen ich nicht glaube auf
jeden fall nochmals wir haben und das
haben sie jetzt hier hat gerade jetzt
gerade da gerne auch in alaska gesagt
denn die könnten besorgen das heißt also
die regierung unsere regierung müsste in
kontakt mit den amerikanern gehen sie
jetzt mal ganz einfach nein konnten hat
mit ralf in havanna das ist es ja auch
dass wir eine milliarde pro tochter
bezahlen wo solange wird dem kunden das
geld geben fördern wir natürlich auch
gleichzeitig den krieg wenn es aber
möglichkeiten gibt die jetzt gerade mit
amerika vielleicht auch noch bei amerika
die research auf jeden fall
für die bestimmte zeit uns zu helfen
dann bestehen da die möglichkeit daran
müsste man dann müsste man meyer wir
gleich direkt bei dem thema sanktionen
und kommen direkt in ihrer these des
heutigen tages die sie beschäftigt
den gedanken den sie heute teilen
möchten also wobei sie heute in der
sendung sprechen möchten
obwohl schreibt ja ich habe heute wie
gesagt ich habe es von anfang alles
schon gesprochen
glauben schwarzenegger hat gerade auf
instagram eine große tolle rede gehalten
indem er eben aus seiner zeit erzählt
als er den großen andere größten
gewichtheber russlands getroffen hatte
persönlich getroffen hatte und
und hat diese nachricht speziell an die
russen gegeben das
ist also ist eine zehn minuten rede die
angeblichen gänsehaut macht und
vielleicht schaut man da auch mal rein
was mich immer also auch befangen macht
das und was ich hörte was sehr sehr
traurig ist dass viele der jungen russin
auch die in den krieg ziehen gegen ihr
eigenes bruderland kämpfen müssen erst
gar nicht wussten dass sie in einem
krieg sind als mutter special operation
genannt und so weiter und ich habe
selbst auch freunde hier in los angeles
die schäme sich dafür die sind dagegen
es gibt also das muss man ganz klar
sagen ein großer großer teil der in
russland diesen krieg nicht möchte ja
das ist also ganz ganz wichtig auch mal
zu sagen auch die deutschland rossen
habe ich gelesen gehört dass die auch
schon bei uns angegriffen wurden die
zweieinhalb millionen auch da müsste man
die leute zufrieden lassen
die schämen sich ja selbst dafür dass
russland da gerade macht und gerade tut
und
ja wir können nur auch immer wieder
hergehen und sagen wir müssen von innen
her versuchen auch dass die russen an
putin rangehen
versuchen ihn zu stürzen weil sie nicht
ob das geht aber das soll tänzen sein
sehr richtig ich würde einmal die frage
zu brauchen vor dem paradies life care
vor ort was herr müller gerade
angesprochen hat mit dem verhältnis dem
bruderkrieg dem verhältnis zwischen
ukrainer und russen wie ist das bei dir
welche erfahrungen was wurde dir erzählt
darüber wie schwer fällt es vielleicht
dann auch ukraine in den krieg zu ziehen
empfindet man sich da noch als brüder
das ist eine wirklich sehr traurige
entwicklung wenn ich daran denke wie es
2013 war während des mannes während der
proteste da haben viele
auch der führenden figuren immer darauf
geachtet dass es nicht gegen russland
interpretiert werden sollte sogar man
wollte auch versuchen putin in
anführungszeichen nicht zu sehr zu
provozieren ich erinnere mich da auch
noch an viele gespräche mit vitali
klitschko wo die mutter aus russland
gebürtig kommt der vater aus der ukraine
man war teil der sowjetunion
das spielte nie eine rolle also es gab
nie eine art feindschaft zwischen der
ukraine und russland
aber das hat sich sehr verändert durch
den krieg bereits im osten ich habe
einen guten freund aus donets kommt der
stadt die schon seit 214 dort umzingelt
wird der wollte einmal zurück in seine
stadt fahren da wurde er fast standen
auf der auf der straße erschossen weil
man ihn als verräter ausgemacht hat weil
an der west ukraine war konnte zum glück
entkommen
gleichzeitig gibt es viele verbindungen
zwischen ukrainern und menschen die in
moskau wohnen oder in anderen teilen
russlands und das ist eine total
verrückte welt der manchmal sitzen wir
hier in kiew und mein ukrainischer
kollege mit dem ich arbeite beruft
seinen russischen freund an der am
telefon ist und er sagt dann wie kannst
du denn hier mit den nazis und das sind
doch überall nazis hier und es ist er
versuchte zu erklären dass das nicht
stimmt aber diese propaganda und da will
ich dem widersprechen das wirklich so
viele also das ist zumindest mein gefühl
dass wirklich die große mehrheit putin
ablehnt das kann ich weder in den
meinungsumfragen erkennen noch in dem
was ich persönlich erlebe also mein
gefühl ist dass diese propaganda noch
zumindest sehr sehr stark dort verfängt
ja das braucht alles seine zeit paul
aber ich habe heute gesehen szenen
gesehen aus moskau das ganz normale
leute auf der strasse sich um zucker
geprügelt haben zucker ist jetzt der
der mangel stoff in russland ist wird
zucker gehortet aus furcht vor hunger
vor allem was was danach kommen kann das
heißt die erkenntnis dass da irgendwo
krieg geführt wird der negative folgen
hat diese erkenntnis ist inzwischen in
russland auch ganz unten angekommen also
ich glaube es gibt nur noch ganz wenige
menschen die glauben die gar nicht
wissen dass da in der kleine irgendwas
stattfindet das braucht alles eine
gewisse zeit aber dann kommt es auch an
und wie wir an der zucker frage sehen
kommt es im leben der normalen merwe an
die machen keine keinen aufstand gegen
putin das wird nicht stattfinden sondern
die frage ist frage ist wann sich jemand
im machtapparat entschließt putin
abzuservieren
da gebe ich dir vollkommen recht dass es
nicht um die massen geht uli nur mein
gefühl ist dass putin unser gesamter
propaganda apparat ist schaffen kann
auch einen mangel an lebensmitteln oder
einen mangel an zucker oder was auch
immer sozusagen dem westen anzulasten
wie in schlimmsten oder eigentlich noch
schlimmere zeiten des kalten krieges
sozusagen die wollen russland klein
machen so wie es jetzt schon versucht
die wollen russland kaputt machen und
wir müssen jetzt gemeinsam hier stehen
gegen die bösen mächte im westen das
verfängt leider immer noch sehr stark
aber wie welche probleme dieser
machtapparat hat ja erkennen wir auch
schon an einem kleinen nebenaspekt die
russische diplomatie im ausland
beispielsweise in berlin der botschafter
hier es nicht zu sehen was sollte er
denn auch sagen zu diesem krieg sollte
er sagen die ukraine eingeladen ja ja
natürlich sagt er ab was soll er denn
sagen die leute haben ihn eingeladen
wird entzieht der es von tausenden
eingeladen worden die ukraine werden
entnazifiziert und entwaffnet soll er
diesen ganzen unsinn erzählen die
diplomaten hier schweigen er das heißt
der ganze auslands apparat des
außenministeriums islam gelegt die
können nur durch praktische arbeit dafür
sorgen dass ein paar dinge noch
funktionieren die sie brauchen aber
argumentieren können sie nicht mehr und
das bleibt nicht ohne rückwirkung auf
moskau da bin ich überzeugt von mir
geben nach zu reif möller dessen these
auch war ich hab sie gerade im
hintergrund bedeutet sie wollten
antworten ist immer etwas schwieriger
wenn man digital zu gescheit ist und
sich direkt einmischen kann
wir haben die diskussion wahrgenommen
und auch das paul natürlich gesagt hat
dass er da er eine verfassung sind die
stadt findet
dass die ich hoffe dass es richtig
verstanden habe also die propaganda die
paula auch angesprochen hat
gerade
die ist ich habe hier einen freund dem
produzenten der mit die letzten tage
sagte er konnte auch die mutter nicht
mal so erreichen also wie gesagt
internet usw das ist ja auch alles
überwiegend abgestellt und so die haben
auch wirklich schwierigkeiten auch
wichtige informationen zu bekommen
damit will man dass das ganze wenn man
sich das wirklich vorstellen dass im
grunde
familien verwandte gegeneinander kämpfen
und dass dieser putin auch noch sagt er
will den nazismus gegen die nazis
kämpfen
der präsident der ukraine dessen vater
hat
europas
33 sind im konzentrations
camp ums leben gekommen er ist jude und
allein schon diese thesen aufzustellen
dieser die sind diese diesen dummen
schwachen thesen an das andere an die
leute zu geben
das zeigt doch dass putin gar kein
interesse hat er führt gespräche gemacht
und lässt doch gleich weiter bomben und
und immer mehr sterben usw nochmals ich
glaube was im moment nicht liefern
waffen liefern ernährung aber was ganz
wichtig ist ist einmal der der flug
himmel also oben das da dass die
natürlich das ist ein ganz ganz großes
problem dass da der russe an fliegen
kann und im luftraum beherrscht und dann
nochmals auch wir müssen den gürtel so
ein bisschen manchmal auch enger
schnallen wir müssen auch schon mal
jetzt war dahinter stehen und es ist
möglich
ich würde auch die akw sachen wieder
also die die warum nicht ich wieder rein
gegeben der franzose baut 15
verschiedene
atomkraftwerke neue und wir schalten die
dinge alle ab ich weiß es hat auch
nachteile aber im moment ist alles das
wichtig wir müssten alles das tun mit
den amerikanern verhandeln akw um
energien mehr zu bekommen alles das was
wir gegen einander was gegen
angesprochen hat ist aber jetzt wichtig
es geht hier um menschenleben und
solange wir
kaufen und den milliarden reinschieben
in den arsch dem putin wird er weiter
brutal kennen und mördern jeden tag das
muss man sich klar eingehen und das
manchmal ein kommt deswegen sage ich mal
wieder sagen ich muss auch noch ein
sagen ich habe das jetzt ja auch schon
jetzt in seit dem kriegsbeginn paul und
seine kollegen kameraleute kam ums leben
auch von amerikanern von fox die vor ort
sind die auch ihr leben riskieren das
ist ein wahnsinn ich hatte damals auch
noch mit vitali gesprochen wenn man das
mal bedenkt wir leben im 22 jahr 22 und
ich habe ihn schreiben müssen dass das
er gebraucht wird das erleben muss dass
die leute ihn brauchen auch den
präsidenten da spricht man zu einem
freund da gibt man ergänze halb über das
dass das jeden tag sterben kann dass ich
glaube dass das geht so das zeigt ja
schon was bei euch da jetzt im bundestag
wieder gelaufen ist die hören sich das
an und schon gehen die zu anderen themen
über nicht sein gemeint wäre sie hatten
ja doch mal was ist so schlimm und
menschen entwürdigend was da gelaufen
ist da kann man sich nur mit dem kopf
schütteln dass das möchte man gar nicht
reinbekommen ja dass die dann dazu
glückwunsch sache nochmal übergehen das
ist mit einem netz immer wieder bewusst
aber wie gesagt solange wir den füttern
ist dieses monster hin so lange wird
dieses monster auch weiter fressen und
töten ganz klar
ein punkt ist ganz entscheidend wie
können wir dafür sorgen dass auch putin
in russland immer kritischer gesehen
wird das ist ja eben auch angeklungen
und je länger der krieg dauert und je
mehr menschen auch in russland das
merken auch wenn das langsam man läuft
war natürlich die propagandamaschine von
putin angeworfen wurde desto größer ist
dann auch die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
putin in schwierigkeiten kommt und
deswegen müssen wir die ukraine auch mit
waffen weiterhin unterstützen damit die
ukraine sich wehren können damit sie
sich verteidigen können denn wenn wir
mal ganz ehrlich sind als der krieg
begonnen hat haben doch die meisten in
deutschland gedacht in zwei drei oder
vier tagen ist putin mit seinen truppen
in die ukraine überall einmarschiert und
die das ukrainische volk hat kaum eine
chance und wir sehen jetzt dass das
ukrainische volk über drei wochen
richtig tapfer und gut gekämpft hat und
dass die gegenhalten und je länger der
krieg dauert desto kritischer wird auch
putin gesehen war natürlich da sein
umfeld das merkt aber auch das russische
volk und da liegt auch meine hoffnung
dass es da langsam eine bewegung in
russland der nachrichten tag war heute
nicht nur geprägt von der ukraine und
ich möchte mich hier auch schon mal an
dieser stelle ganz herzlich bedanken bei
ihnen herr müller sie bleiben mehr als
bei unserem zweiten teil der sendung
aber das war ein wirklich
beeindruckender appel und wir
verabschieden uns jetzt bei paul
ronzheimer dem bild fiel zudem hilft
jeden tag berichtet ich könnte es nicht
besser sagen als er reif müller und ich
bin sehr stolz seine kollegin zu sein
und wir sehen uns morgen abend wieder
paul und sie sehen uns gleich nach einer
kurzen unterbrechung wieder bis gleich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bild
das box highlight live bei bild
[Musik]
felix sturm auf dem weg zum
weltmeistertitel
der kampf gegen israel
willkommen zurück
die boxnacht am
26 märz bei bild diese sendung wird
präsentiert von governor of poker tragen
die gratis poker app fürs handy
bild
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zurück liebe
zuschauer nach acht meine gäste heute
abend sind cdu-politiker und
bundestagsabgeordneter christoph ploß
den hollywoodstar ralf möller sie werden
ihn kennen und last but not least
journalisten jörges wir haben in der
ersten hälfte weil die ukraine und
russland debattiert und kommen jetzt zur
zweiten hälfte corinna dentoni die
pandemie und wie man jetzt noch damit
umgehen sie mit welchen maßnahmen
darüber die politik heute stark
gestritten würde ich sagen auch über die
impfpflicht und ich freue mich sehr dass
wir uns jetzt die these von herr jörges
anhören und ja ich bin der meinung
leider dass der traum von freiheit ein
traum bleibt der zwanzigste märz sollte
ja eigentlich freedom day werden also
der das ende aller krone einschränkungen
die es in deutschland gibt nun merken
wir der freedom day wird zum king day
also zum betrugs tag denn die
bundesländer fast alle haben schon
beschlossen dass sie die geltenden
maßnahmen verlängern werden um zwei
wochen bis zum 2 april das gibt es eine
übergangsfrist im neuen
infektionsschutzgesetz und sollte das
vorbei sein kommt das nächste hinterher
und da wird glaube ich noch schamloser
beschissen denn da geht es darum
geht es darum die die die länder also in
großen einheiten zu hotspot zu erklären
da kann man dann alles weiterführen was
man bisher schon hat da geht es also
nicht mehr darum dass einzelne ortsteile
oder ort ein hotspot sind sondern ganze
bundesländer und karl lauterbach da
munter die länder geradezu dazu das ist
ein betrug am koalitionspartner fdp denn
die fdp wollte den freedom day und der
leider hat der justizminister marco
buschmann sich über den tisch ziehen
lassen und nun wird die ausnahmeregelung
für hot spots möglicherweise zur general
regelung dann können wir auf den sankt
nimmerleinstag warten bis wir endlich
frei sind das grün regierte baden
württemberg ist ganz vorne beim beschiss
an den menschen es gibt keine probleme
in baden württembergischen kliniken es
gibt 5000 corona betten dort davon sind
1800 in normal stationen belegt und 250
auf intensivstationen also alles ganz
normal friedlich unaufgeregt der
entscheidende punkt ist dass die masken
pflicht zum fetisch der chronisten
geworden ist die wollen sie die
verteidigen sie mit zähnen und klauen
denn solange die menschen auch beim
einkaufen im supermarkt gezwungen sind
eine maske anzulegen gehen sie in die
knie vor der dunklen macht das ist die
dunkle macht der chronisten sie bleiben
unfrei immerhin die ungeimpften geraten
ein stück weit zurück ins leben weil
glaube ich die impfpflicht im bundestag
scheitern wird sie wird nicht kommen das
haben die ungeimpften auch verdient sie
sind auf eine weise aus dem leben
ausgeschlossen
diskriminiert so soll er bereits
nachgesagt er ist für die im plus auch
mal leute anfang an gesagt aber ich kann
keine mehrheit erkennen für eine
impfpflicht ab 18 jedenfalls
das ist
hast du mich aus dem konzept gebracht
man erkennt nicht nur in einer ergänzt
bitte nicht
die
die ungeimpften sind ein kleines stück
ins leben zurück gekommen sie können
wieder teilnehmen an leben nachdem sie
vorher unverschämt und systematisch
diskriminiert und ausgeschlossen worden
sind mein bild von deutschland hat das
verändert ich sehe deutschland heute
anders und ich schäme mich dafür und da
niemand den mund auf kriegt in dieser
hinsicht will ich heute abend die
symbolische den symbolischen schritt
wagen ich bitte die ungeimpften um
verzeihung bei der sich immer eingesetzt
dafür gegen die spaltung das hier
nochmal das ärgert mich nicht daran das
zu sagen das stimmt absolut ich geb dir
auch recht ich schäme mich in der
hinsicht auch deutsch zu sein für diese
spaltung aber einer der ist glaube ich
nicht tut ist christoph ploß oder du
hast ja nicht dieselbe ansicht uni und
ich kann also ich finde erst mal dass
auch das was jetzt vorgelegt wurde von
einer ampelkoalition teilweise murks ist
und auch hier sieht man wieder die eine
hand weiß nicht was die andere macht
nennen auf der einen seite zieht herr
buschmann sagt freedom day und
freiheiten und die einschränkungen
sondern fein und auf der anderen seite
haben wir karl lauterbach der ja schon
in den vergangenen wochen ein alarm
minister war so und deswegen man erkenne
überhaupt keine strategie und kein linie
und das führt jetzt vor allem dazu dass
wir wieder zum flickenteppich kommen
werden denn die bundesländer die können
ja teilweise einzelne maßnahmen
einführen und dann haben wir die
situation dass zum beispiel zwischen
kiel und hamburg und zwischen
brandenburg und berlin völlig
unterschiedliche richtlinien gelten und
das war immer das was wir ja von anfang
an verhindern wollten und deswegen ist
das was da jetzt gemacht wurde echter
marx ich würde aber trotzdem noch
unterscheiden und auch etwas
differenzieren ich bin sehr dafür dass
wir jetzt endlich wieder die
freiheitsrechte und grundrechte
weitestgehend zurück erlangen juli maske
es gibt ist auf entfielen er meint es
gibt in vielen bereichen eine
legitimation mehr das jetzt zum beispiel
in berlin ich glaube nur 25.000 menschen
ins stadion gehen können bei hertha bsc
verstehe ich nicht wobei ich jetzt heute
gelesen hat die nachfrage sowie so
geringer weil die man im trainingslager
die masten pflicht halte ich zum
beispiel im öffentlichen nahverkehr oder
auch in supermärkten für sinnvoll weil
da die virologen sagen das ist eine sehr
effektive maßnahme und da sind die
einschränkungen sehr gering also wenn
ich alle anderen grund und
freiheitsrechte zurückbekommen aber weiß
ich stoppe das virus sehr stark mit
masken zum beispiel beim einkaufen dann
bin ich nach wie vor finden mussten wir
sehen doch in anderen ländern die ihren
frieden mit allen längst wähler längst
hinter sich haben können wir doch sehen
dass die abschaffung der massen pflicht
nichts verschlimmert hat gar nichts in
england laufen in london laufen die
menschen längst ohne masten rum da gibt
es jetzt keine red wochen da gibt es
keinen kann ausspruch von johnson muss
an den ein oder anderen freedom day auch
schon zurück
die warrants oder habe ich teilweise
allemal die hoheit weise weil die
teilweise auch viel zu früh geöffnet hat
oder
etwas kann man nur sagen alles super
gelebt
du hast jetzt wirklich die längste these
heute gehabt dies stoppen letzten wochen
gab und ich liebe dich erhielten wir
einmal ich meine wir haben ja heute
jemand in einem anderen land wir haben
ja dieses privileg bescheiden zu reif
müller nach amerika und wollen doch
einfach mal wissen wie läuft denn dort
ab gibt es noch die maske pflicht wie
fühlt sich ein in amerika gerade zu
leben ist es das land der freiheit
wieder geworden ja also wir können
selbst entscheiden ob eine maske trägt
oder nicht
ich stimme da ganz klar zu und und muss
sagen das ja wir haben das jetzt zwei
jahre wer sich impfen lassen wollte hat
sich geimpft jeder ist für sich selbst
verantwortlich irgendwann muss auch
damit mal schluss sein
ich habe was ich in den letzten zwei
drei wochen noch mitbekommen habt das
habt ihr wahrscheinlich auch schon
gehört dass es leute gibt viele die
wurden zweimal geimpft also 2 plus und
so weiter und haben trotzdem krone
bekommen sie also auch geschmacksverlust
auch kommt nicht riechen und so weiter
also es ist halt da draußen ich kann nur
eins sagen geht in die fitnessstudios
trainiert paar muskeln muskeln machen
stark und regine freie bzw stürzt also
eigenes system es wird wie die grippe
sein krone wird nicht mehr wegzudenken
sein wenn wir jetzt die grippe zum
beispiel aufziehen würden dann hätten
wir auch hunderttausende pro tag die
sich irgendwo anstecken es ist nun mal
so weit wir haben ganz wichtig glaube
ich jetzt was ich so mitbekommt dass
also als in den krankenhäusern keine
überbelastung mehr ist das was wir
damals alles hatten das ist ja nicht mal
klar aber dass sich menschen anstecken
werden wieder die geimpft wurden oder
nicht geimpft wurden das wird immer
weiter aber
wir bleiben wir bleiben bei dem thema
kronen wir bleiben bei dem thema
impfpflicht bei müller ist war es war
gerade richtig wohltuend das mal zu
hören dass ja auch das impfen die
freiheit von jedem einzelnen ich zeige
ihnen jetzt etwas ich glaube das wird
sie in amerika wahrscheinlich ebenso
schockieren die mich in mein thema ist
heute abend nicht die die nicht die
ungeimpften rauben uns die freie sollen
die politiker ich bin ja ein sehr sehr
viel unsinn gewöhnt und auch an plumpe
erklärungen an ausreden warum alles so
bleiben muss kann bestimmung jahre von
politikern lauterbach hat beispielsweise
bei menschen die sich nicht gegen coop
19 haben impfen lassen gesagt das ganze
land wird in der geiselhaft dieser
menschen sein das muss man sich mal
vorstellen als gesundheitsminister so
etwas spielerisches zu sagen aber heute
heute wurde ich dann so richtig
überrascht beziehungsweise hat mich
völlig schockiert die jüngste
bundestagsabgeordnete emilia fester hat
heute wirklich in der impfpflicht
debatte allen davor da gewesen die krone
aufgesetzt und hören sie doch jetzt mal
gemeinsam mit ralf möller ich denke die
beiden studio kennen schon rein wie
emilia fest dass ich heute aufgeführt
hat
das mag ihn jetzt vielleicht lächerlich
vorkommen aber wissen sie was wirklich
lächerlich ist wenn sie und ihre
freundinnen der freiheit sich einfach
hätten impfen lassen als die meisten von
uns so vernünftig waren in diesen
einfachen schritt gegangen sind dann
dann wäre ich jetzt zeit
denn wenn wir alle wieder frei oder
zumindest
um das zu machen was wir lieben und
worauf ihn seit zwei jahren warten was
manche von uns depressiv macht ja ja ist
depressiv ich muss emilia fester an der
stelle enttäuschen weil emilia fest und
auch wir alle werden unsere freiheit
nicht zurück erlangen indem wir menschen
zur impfung zwingen sondern wir bekommen
die freiheit zurück wenn die politik
endlich umdenkt und das schöne sich habt
ihr heute in der runde ein unions
abgeordneten sitzen und da ist natürlich
meine frage an sie herr plus hat sich
die union denn richtig feind wie stehen
sie denn jetzt heute war wir haben dich
ja mehr denn wer meinen anderen fall
gebracht also das was da frau fester
gesagt hat fand ich auch in der form
völlig daneben so wird auch eine
gesellschaft nicht zusammengeführt auch
wenn sie bei den grünen wahrscheinlichen
fleißigen kriegt weil sie korrekt
geändert hat aber das war kein auftritt
der für unser land gut sind und
natürlich ist was wir ja gesagt haben
also die impfpflicht kann ja unter
gewissen umständen sinnvoll sein wenn
man sicherstellen kann es kommt nicht
zur lok downs wir haben dadurch keine
überlastung auf den intensivstationen
und wir können damit im prinzip
verhindern dass grund und
freiheitsrechte eingeschränkt werden das
sind die bedingung aber die müssen auch
sichergestellt werden und im moment ist
es ja tatsächlich so dass wir im wissen
der impfstoff der hilft nicht so ganz
und gegen nikon haben wir noch keinen
wirklichen impfstoff es gibt viele impf
durchbrüche und wir haben derzeit keine
überlastung der intensivstation und wenn
diese bedingungen nicht gegeben sind
also dass man sagt da droht wirklich
wieder etwas das die intensivstation
überlastet werden dass ärzte nicht mehr
nachkommen dann finde ich gibt es auch
kein argument für eine impfpflicht und
deswegen haben wir als cdu gesagt wir
müssen jetzt uns schon darauf
vorbereiten auch auf den herbst und
winter und wenn wir wissen wir haben
einen impfstoff und es kommt wieder zu
einer schwierigeren situation dann
können wir über eine impfpflicht
entsprechen und möglicherweise auch die
karte ziehen aber wir dürfen nicht auf
einmal sagen wir beschließen einfach so
eine impfpflicht einfach so weil man das
gut findet und wenn diese im pflicht
nicht bringt nichts bringt dann wäre es
auch nicht sinnvoll und deswegen ist das
was die cdu und csu vorgeschlagen haben
genau der richtige mittelweg dass man
weiß man kann reagieren wenn es im
nächsten herbst und winter wieder nach
oben schießt denn das haben wir ja in
der letzten saison auch erlebt und das
hat dann wieder dazu geführt das ist
total locker uns kommt und das möchte
ich verhindern eines sage ich ganz
gewiss ein hammer dann ohne hast du jede
zeit eine frage nur einmalig gibt es
gibt viele schauspieler in deutschland
die schon gesagt habe wie beispielsweise
natalia wörner sie würden nicht mit
ungeimpften drehen wenn es jetzt eine
anfrage bei ihnen gäbe fortsetzung
gladiator ich weiß es nicht würden sie
auch mit einer ungeimpften person drehen
oder sehen sie dass wir manche
schauspieler hier bei uns in diesem land
dass die frage kommt kann gar nicht
aufkommen weil wie gesagt es ist so dass
wenn man an einem set geht eben halt
impfpflicht besteht ich habe jetzt
gerade vorletzten im dezember noch super
bowl commercial gedreht und wenn da wo
ich zweimal getestet welches einmal
positiv getestet worden dann hätte ich
dir nicht machen können also also am set
findet nach wie vor
noch im moment finden dort im fokus
stand man muss geimpft sein wenn man das
nicht macht dann hast du keinen job
was mich aufregt ist die unbelehrbarkeit
der politik wir führen heute wieder in
die diskussion auf basis der inzidenz
wir waren uns mal vor mindestens mal im
jahr einig dass die nichts mehr aussagen
sondern dass wir auch die kliniken
schauen wie viele leute liegen da mit
ernsthaften cupid erkrankungen in
behandlung das ist völlig harmlos heute
da redet aber kein mensch mehr drüber
sondern herr lauterbach und an reden
wieder über die inzidenz als wäre nichts
gewesen und da muss ich sagen das ist
schon wie soll ich das nennen das nenne
ich groß haft weil die wissen es besser
aber sie wollen es gerne so haben weil
sie natürlich sich selber im geschäft
halten wollen auch im politischen
geschäft ich habe das früher mal kroner
mafia genannt und bin dafür heftig
kritisiert worden aber für mich gehört
karl lauterbach ist ein kopf der korona
mafia die leben davon dass es corona
gibt das sie die gesellschaft in schach
halten und dass sie der gesellschaft
auferlegen was sie zu tun oder zu lassen
hat und davon habe ich jetzt die nase
voll denn wir wissen dass dieses virus
was jetzt unterwegs ist relativ harmlos
ist das kann im halben jahr anders
aussehen deswegen ist ja unser vorschlag
auch jahr richtig aber es argumentieren
sie doch heute mal mit gegen lauterbach
was mache ich doch gemein das sagen
haben sagen alle minister anderen haben
einen einsatz nach ist also die
cdu-ministerpräsidenten rennen wenn alle
rum und widersprechen auch dem neuen
infektionsschutz havarie am karl
lauterbach sagte häufig haben ich habe
in der sendung gesagt er sind alle
minister ist ein angst minister weil er
tatsächlich im moment angst und
schrecken verbreitet und das schlimme
ist ja wenn ich das wenn herr lauterbach
das jeden tag tut dann wird man ihn auch
nicht ernst nehmen wenn es mal drauf
ankommt weil sich das irgendwann abnutzt
und wir müssen genau die situation in
den krankenhäusern im blick behalten
wenn es zum beispiel eine neue mutante
gibt die dazu führt dass die
krankenhäuser überfüllt werden könnten
dass die intensivstation überlastet sein
könnten da muss man natürlich reagieren
aber derzeit eher york ist da haben sie
völlig recht ist das virus eher so etwas
wie ein schnupfen bei den meisten
menschen und es sorgt nicht dafür dass
die intensivstation überfüllt sind wird
derzeit gibt es im moment auch kein
grund für eine impfpflicht aber man muss
sich immer leichter fertig wäre gleich
weil weil wir dürfen eines nicht erleben
dass wir nochmal drittes mal in herbst
und winter gehen neben untergrund und
freiheitseinschränkung kommt der männer
viel herzlichen dank sich zeit genommen
haben
absolut recht nochmals jeder ist für
sich selbst verantwortlich
trainiert ernährt euch richtig genau und
lasst euch nicht weiter verrückt von ab
und zu liberalen frauen sowohl durch
eine zigarre
sehr gut es fehlen dann greifen weiler
dankeschön
also jetzt wurden wir wieder unter
brauch in der diskussion uli diesmal
aber nicht von mir sondern von den
reifen wenn
ich wollte nochmal dem entgegenhalten
sie argumentieren im hinblick auf die
impfpflicht dort haben sie recht das
schildern sie immer den denn den
gesetzentwurf der union ich rede hier
über die augenblicke die diskussion wie
wir um den frieden day betrogen werden
und da spielen die ministerin union eine
gute rolle denn die machen alarmstimmung
die sorgen dafür dass das alles zunächst
mal bis zum zweiten april verlängert
wird und dann auch noch jetzt darüber
hinaus denn es gibt eine ganze reihe von
cdu ministerpräsidenten die sich
vorgenommen haben darüber wird heute
offen diskutiert und zwar mit karl
lauterbach die fdp zu betrügen und die
ganze beschränkung geschichte
fortzusetzen das sehe ich anders gerade
cdu ministerpräsidenten haben sich dafür
eingesetzt dass diese maßnahmen zur
milliardärin kommt dass die maßnahmen am
ryck genommen werden ja ich finde diesen
begriff freedom day etwas übertrieben
der hat jetzt in der politischen
diskussion keine rolle gespielt ist aber
was wir damit meint ja aber dass das ist
ja so ein kunstbegriff der jetzt ja in
den diskussionen wo man tatsächlich dann
ganz konkret sagen muss wollen wir dass
die menschen zum beispiel wieder ins
fußballstadion gehen können oder nicht
und da haben sich zum beispiel gerade
die cdu-politiker sehr dafür eingesetzt
dass die menschen wieder im schönen
tragen masken
keine eigenen das andere auge
ich bin auch ich bin zum beispiel dafür
dass die massen pflicht an den schulen
weit zurückgenommen wird es hängt immer
auch von der schule ab also man muss
jetzt mal gucken von bundesland zu
bundesland wobei ich ein punkt ganz
interessant wenn wir ich habe das selber
auch schon häufiger gesagt es gibt
gerade dann eltern die sich beschweren
und sagen das ist aber zu gefährlich
also das ist nicht unumstritten er an
einem großen so gibt es alles ich will
jedenfalls ich habe die nase voll von
der massen pflicht im supermarkt solltet
ihr mal gestopft voll sein ziehe ich mir
vielleicht freiwillig einer auf aber ich
will da nicht zu gezwungen werden
ständig eine zu tragen
christoph ploß julia bis morgen abend 20
[Musik]
wir sind mittendrin
wir zeigen die wahrheit
egal wem sie wehtut
[Musik]
haben wir doch alle